good morning it gets Tuesday it's
actually Saturday but we're on our way
to Europe we packed up and we're going
to Europe but where are we going first
henry north carolina bubu alice the sun
is shining the sky is blue and we're
feeling alright and now indeed Hank we
are in Asheville where noted American
heroes Mom and Dad will be taking care
of our kids for the next week while
we're in Europe mom and dad's house
house flowers and chickens and goats and
grilled cheese with the crust cut off
plus there's a fairy garden all around
the garden mom has installed these tiny
little fairies that everyone can search
for it's like a scavenger hunt and
there's a golden doodle I think she's
currently urinating good job Casey way
to do that outside oh it's a pits poop
it's a poop and now having dropped off
the kids we returned to the airport to
fly to a somewhat less wooded location
I've arrived in New York just in time to
get on the flight to Madrid Hank so
hopefully I will sleep for that entire
flight here's an observation videotaping
yourself with your eyes closed is not
the same thing as sleeping I continue to
find it very difficult to sleep on
airplanes Hank because there's always
this little voice inside of me reminding
me that I am 34,000 feet above the
ground which is a situation that calls
not for sleeping but for ceaseless
vigilance not great so Hank there's a
lot of ways to deal with jetlag I don't
like to judge people's ways our way
today is that we're going to attempt the
Dory from Finding Nemo which goes just
keep swimming took a shower had some
caffeine change clothes still haven't
slept feeling good let's go to a museum
so Hank we're now at the Reina Sofia Art
Museum just keep swimming saw some cool
stuff like Carl Andre took one of those
glass elevators I hate while NAT
struggled to remain standing saw a very
good early Picasso and then looked at
people looking at the great Picasso
painting Guernica and there was also
this great Warhol and in every room they
had films from similar periods of
history which was a fascinating
curatorial choice not spent a long time
watching this one now and I had become
really close over the last year and a
half and among the many gifts he's given
me is an appreciation for movies I used
to think of them just as like lessard
novels but Knott's helped me to
understand that movies are valuable and
fascinating in and of themselves he's a
great actor but he's
so a brilliant person and so let me just
quickly say while his back is turned
I love you nat wolff alright moving on
so now we're gonna go to lunch it's
fried bacon them okay hey God now that I
have to end the video now because we're
so tired and we still have two miles to
walk but I'm gonna be John Green when I
grow up and I just hope I'm that wolf
when I grow up
Oh Hank I'll see you on Friday
bye glad you didn't get hit by that car
that would have been really bad for
press